[Music]
today for our daily cancellation maxine
waters enters the ring it may seem
surprising maxine waters has been
canceled i think maybe only once or
twice
in this segment before she could of
course be canceled every day and that
explains why she rarely is it'd be sort
of redundant to cancel her every time
she deserves it
we have to pick our spots the thing
about representative maxine waters is
that she is equal parts stupid evil and
racist
and this can make it especially
difficult to figure out whether any
particular thing she does or says or
policy she proposes
was motivated more by her stupidity her
wickedness or her racism
often it's an equal and equitable mix of
all three i think that's probably the
case here
waters has proposed a plan to give
americans
some help in making a down payment on
their first homes
this may or may not sound like a good
idea to you at first blush
but before you draw any conclusions you
have to remember this is maxine waters
we're talking about here this is the
modern democrat party were talking about
their plans to help americans are never
plans to help
all americans that's why as a politico
headline puts it the real purpose of
this proposal is to quote close the
racial wealth gap
of course everything is always racial
for these people just as there's only
ever six degrees of separation between
any
hollywood actor and kevin bacon there's
only ever at least
or at most two degrees of separation
between any democratic policy proposal
and their racial obsessions it always
comes back to that always
so let's read now from the political
article to get the gist of this plan
it says a 10 billion proposal by house
financial services chair
maxine waters would get would give home
buyers up to 25 000
for a down payment president joe biden's
top housing official hud secretary
martial fudge
which is just a great name for a
bureaucrat
says such assistance is a priority for
the administration
okay pausing there for a second 10
billion dollars
well what's 10 billion dollars between
friends
there are reports this morning that
biden is about to unveil a six
trillion dollar budget six trillion
dollars
now as ben pointed out on twitter 6
trillion is actually 12 trillion when
you factor in the covet stimulus
his family's plan etc
that's all of the proposed spending in
just six months
he's proposing an average of 12 2
trillion dollars a month he has proposed
on average
by the end of his tenure at this rate
he'll have spent
i don't know what 96 trillion dollars if
my math is right which it probably isn't
either way the fact remains these are
astronomical amounts of money these are
such large amounts of money
that you can't even really call them
amounts of money
these numbers are so large they
effectively don't exist
there's no way to conceptualize them
biden is spending money as if there is
no such thing as money
i would say spending money like it grows
on trees but we need more trees than
exist
on earth to harvest this much so 10
billion dollars
that is pocket change i suppose but even
so it's a terrible plan for reasons that
should
already be clear but will only become
clearer as we keep reading
it says waters plan has triggered
concern in the mortgage industry that uh
because it would require lenders to
identify and direct aid to
first-generation buyers
those whose parents don't own homes and
by the way i have
no idea how they would even identify
that group and it does
and they don't really have any idea how
they would either there isn't some
um database out there as far as i know
of americans who've never bought homes
before
anyway and it would also direct the aid
to socially and economically
disadvantaged groups
the move is also stirring broader
criticism about how much it would help
buyers and whether it would even put
them at risk
we are simply providing first generation
home buyers largely people of color what
white first-time home buyers have been
receiving for years in the form of
the daddy down payment loan family
assistance that is almost never repaid
said dave and david dworkin president
and ceo of the national housing
conference
an advocacy group the plan with the most
traction the 10 billion
proposal in a housing infrastructure
bill by waters would give state housing
finance
agencies grants to award up to 20
thousand dollars in down payment
assistance to first generation home
buyers
below a certain income threshold and up
to twenty five thousand dollars if the
home buyer is from a socially
and economically disadvantaged group
waters bill includes the provision
alongside massive investments in public
housing and the national housing trust
fund
the bill defines socially disadvantaged
home buyers who would require or qualify
for larger credit
as individuals identifying as black
hispanic
native american or asian american
but such presumption may be rebutted
with credible evidence to the contrary
according to a discussion draft of the
legislation so there it is
if you didn't know any better and you
hear someone say that they want to help
the
socially disadvantaged you might think
that sounds like a fine idea
but then you learn that socially
disadvantaged is just a slightly more
sanitized way of saying
anyone who isn't white the plan here
isn't so much to help black people or
minorities it's to
not help white people they are after all
the only group left off the list even
asians are on the list of socially
disadvantaged but asians have a
higher median household income than
whites in this country
asians are doing better than white
people and by a pretty significant
margin
whites are in fact more quote
disadvantaged
than asians the fact that they qualify
the asians that qualify for assistance
and white people don't proves if it
wasn't clear already
that the real point here is simply to
exclude whites
because they're white it's racist and
illegal
the constitution guarantees equal
protection under the law regardless of
race
laws that dole out perks based on race
while leaving whites in the cold are
unconstitutional by definition
now the argument that activists give for
this racist plan as you heard
is that white people have been getting
help from their parents
on their down payments and so it's only
fair if black people get help from the
government
the problem with that argument is first
of all not all white people have parents
who give them money to make down
payments
mine didn't i've bought three homes
no i don't own three homes but we've
moved you know three times in the last
four years and i bought
homes in each place um i didn't get any
help on any of those down payments
and besides here's a concept that more
people need to understand
the government is not your daddy
there are plenty of things that parents
do or can do
which the government can't do or
shouldn't do
and anyway whatever the government is
doing it is it is racist and
illegal to favor certain groups based on
race while excluding others on the same
basis
aside from the racial component though
the whole idea of down payment
assistance from the government
is catastrophically awful on its own
merits
even the race stuff aside a pretty good
general principle is this
if you can't afford to make a down
payment on a home
then you can't afford the home if you
need 25 grand from daddy government in
order to afford even just the down
payment
how are you going to pay your mortgage
going forward what about utilities
hoa fees if you have will you have money
to fix a leaky pipe or a broken hvac
unit
many expenses come with home ownership
believe me i'm
we're going through that right now as
people just recently bought a home
throwing people into homes they can't
afford all in the name of racial equity
is a disaster waiting to happen
especially now as the housing market is
challenging enough for buyers
it's very hard to find a house right now
again i know what i'm talking about
because the demand is through the roof
and the houses that are available are
all more expensive
expensive than they'd be in a normal
market and they're getting more
expensive every day
now throw a bunch of homeowners or
potential homeowners with a check from
the government into the mix
and you just made it harder for buyers
not easier more expensive not more
affordable
it's a bad idea on every level foolish
short-sighted
ridiculous also racist
exactly what we've come to expect from
maxine waters and friends
and that is why she is today of course
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right
down there so you can stay up to date on
all of our future content